wait i was so um surprised but in a good
way to see you on the tip sheet tonight
you just
love it from vegas to texas you can't
stay away from the iheart family i can't
i knew you're gonna be here so i had to
come
he says anyone's ever said well you
crushed the presenting how'd it feel to
be out there i felt amazing i mean i've
i haven't been on that big of a stage in
a pretty long time so oh never mind
since i heard i was just here deja vu it
was like two months ago in vegas i know
oh my god no the crowd was lively it's
exciting do you like country music i do
i i mean obviously it's not my genre but
um i love the storytelling in it and
especially being over there with amy
brown she was super exciting super cool
songwriting and country music oh it'll
cut your soul it will i literally got
into country music like two months ago
and now i'm obsessed oh my god only two
months ago okay so who's your favorite
like what are you listening to thomas
rhett
sam hunt you know those are like my guys
so do you know who toby keith is here
tonight
stop it i don't know that's what i'm
saying i'm new i'm a newbie you at least
know blake shelton right oh yeah
toby keith
performed here
he's a big name in country look him up
after also george strait he's like the
king of country he's the surprise guest
so
you gotta have some homework listen i
need your playlist i will share some
with you but you gotta you gotta do your
part and you gotta catch up on your own
i will i'm gonna do it is it date night
for you tonight here uh date night
uh yeah i would say i mean my
girlfriend's here my sister's here so
we're having they're having some fun out
there i thought i saw your girlfriend
that's really sweet that she was
actually here um filming the tv as you
were presenting that's crazy oh she saw
me i thought she missed me that's good
i i can attest she was back here filming
your presentation yes thank you for
telling me that look at the smile on
your face
i'm blushing
have you guys been together now
10 months
yeah
it's coming up coming up to a year soon
what are you gonna do to celebrate
i don't know i mean we're gonna have to
do something i mean she flew out here
because i'm filming a movie out here so
i just happened to get to see her
because it's been like two weeks so
we'll figure it out you gotta help me
with that too people love the best it is
the best it really is like amazing
feeling how would you say she has
changed your life
man it's kind of like indescribable um
i think just continuing to keep me like
grounded and like just be present and i
get to do this for a living i mean which
is really cool so i just got to remember
to you know this is like a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity so to
have a partner and a teammate who's able
to support you in this way like it's the
best thing in the entire world it
literally is like your biggest fan
number one fan always there for you it's
an amazing feeling i love it and also
you're in a position to as a musician
where they can serve as inspiration for
your art that's what i'm saying it's all
about the art too so you get so much
inspiration from your partner so i was
gonna say is being in love helping to
inspire more new music for you oh a
thousand percent i mean before like past
relationships like writing songs and not
knowing those certain feelings was kind
of like tough for me so now that i've
experienced that and i've gone through
it it's way more relatable for me so
well listen between being in love and
then also now diving into country music
you are gonna have the best love songs
in the history of love songs my friend
you're so right i'm gonna have to like
put out a country song or something
it'd be cool i want to do everything so
crazier things have happened i think you
diving into country music is a-okay
you're right you're right you're right
so you're filming a movie here in austin
what can you tell us probably not i
really can't tell you absolutely
anything um
actually i can actually because so it's
basically like a survival action movie
about this family that um
is trying to escape this raging fire
that takes over this town and that's all
i'm really gonna say but it's a really
fun movie a really great script and um i
get to work with peter falcinelli who is
twilight obviously and
yeah it's exciting can't wait what drew
you to the role
it's a good question
i feel like my character in the role is
just a sweet
soft-spoken kid
it's kind of how i was at 15 years old
like trying to figure out my my everyday
life like just figuring out figuring out
me at 15 so i really like those
qualities so again the relatability
that's it you just posted on instagram
the other day with a caption just
getting started where are we going where
are we where are we going we're going to
mexico um yeah we're just getting
started
we're coming we're coming hot i mean
this this new year where are we 60 days
away from it being 20. don't tell me
that i got a christmas shot that's so
weird oh my god halloween christmas i
know halloween thanksgiving one year
anniversary
well no way actually halloween
thanksgiving your one year anniversary
christmas well actually it all falls i
don't know the date but it all falls at
the same time how am i supposed to keep
track
planner
everything all of you
[Music]